رفض الخدمه العسكريه هو نهايه الديمقراطيه
ويشكل خطرا على امن كل الاسرائيليين
اخبار العلم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم
اتساع النطاق العصيان في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي احتجاجا على قانون التعديلات
القضائيه اكثر من الف طيار وفني في سلاح
الجو اوقف نشاطهم التطوعي كما اتسع نطاق
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في حين قالت المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ان نتنياهو يقود البلاد الى
حرب اهليه
بعد تحذير لاوكرانيا روسيا تجري مناورات
على اهداف بالبحر الاسود واوكرانيا ترد
بتعذير السفن المتجهه للموانئ الروسيه
وتتهم روسيا بالتصعيد وبقصف منشاه للحبوب
في اوديسا بدوره قال بوتين ان محاولات
اوكرانيا شن هجوم مضاد تبوء بالفشل واتهم
بولندا بالسعي للدخول في الصراع
طاعه بارتفاع اسعار الارز بشكل كبير في
الايام المقبله وذلك بعد توقف تجارتها في
اسيا بسبب الحظر الذي فرضته الهند اكبر
مورد للارز في العالم على تصدير حصه كبيره
من صادراتها للحد من ارتفاع الاسعار محليا
طفله امريكيه تحصل على تعويض بثمان مائه
الف دولار من ماكدونالدز الطفله تعرضت
لحريق اثراء سقوط قطعه دجاج ساخنه على
تغذيها في حين قالت الشركه انها اتبعت
قواعد سلامه الاغذيه التي تتطلب ان تكون
ساخنه لتجنب تسمم السلمونيلا
الى اللقاء